[Music]
let's start with a Sammy doll have you
spoken to Sammy has she said anything
about it
I have I have and she gets the job she's
she's she knows it was all in good fun
yeah I'm glad too because I was like
shoot I hope she doesn't hate me
you know I know you're really close with
her and you defended her all season long
you were such a good friend why was that
important to you and what kind of
conversations have you guys had it was
important to me because I would hope if
I wasn't in the house she would do the
same for me and I really think she would
um I told her like I wasn't gonna let
anybody really talk bad about her and
she's fine she she thinks the whole
thing was funny she doesn't care did she
hear that Ronny admitted that he still
has feelings for her doesn't really care
to talk about Ron
so he's a master of oh yeah so we don't
really talk about Ron very much I mean I
did I was like what do you think about
the doll you know like whatever like she
was like actually the voice box is
pretty funny so I was like say she's a
good she's a good sport after all yeah
and I want to say thanks so heavy the
cast of Jersey Shore exclusively dishing
on Sammy sweethearts sort of cameo in
season one a family vacation to et but
will she really pop up next season will
we see actual Sammy yeah maybe even if
like Iran goes on vacation because you
also brought in Angelina I did I did I
like to bring guests Angelina you
poo-poo pants no it was like period
we made over the idea what really
happened if TV could allow percent we
Mansell's have you guys kept your word
have you been hanging out with her
I recently unblocked her finally Yeah
right seven years oh good and yeah I've
had my first conversation already with
her is she in the group text no no not
there yes mr. hunter steps first will we
see her in Vegas no no God is he filming
so we can't really give you too much you
do you want to see her yeah she makes me
laugh to be honest
Angelina not in the group text chain yet
but one thing that is well excitement
for the show is possible Emmy
nominations what was the last thing in
the group chat we send a billboard of
the consideration for them yeah yeah
okay I want to talk to you guys about
this is amazing you guys might be
nominated for multiple Emmy yeah what do
you think the chances are I think that
when we did it the first time that
category didn't exist in the past yeah
so now we have a chance be honest is
that why you wanted to do this reunion
we were like just like eight Guido's
from you know the Jersey area we never
expected to be in the conversation of
Emmys and so it's so dope to be in
consideration
[Music]